still developing tonight new rules for
students at desert oasis high school the
changes come after a fight led to
gunshots during a football game last
friday night sasha loftus live tonight
with how parents feel about these recent
changes
brian tonight's game kicked off about 30
minutes ago we can hear those cheers and
really everyone enjoying but again after
a fight broke out at last week's game
and led to gunfire new safety measures
are in place
a letter sent to parents said no
backpacks or bags are allowed students
must get their tickets ahead of time
online and present their school id when
they arrive they also must have a parent
come with them we spoke with a student
ahead of the game who didn't want to
share her name but says she's all for
these changes
we get to know that there's actually
like stuff being
put down to like
i don't know like precautionary measures
just in case anything happens just makes
us feel safer anyone who came here to
see the visiting team also has to show
id at the door
again the game kicked off at 5 30
tonight and that letter said that games
here at desert oasis will start at 5 30
from here on out reporting live in the
southwest valley tonight sasha loftis 8
news now